The Wand holds
an unfathomable power.
If a man cloaked in light wields it,
the world shall be brightly lit.
But if a man cloaked in darkness
brandishes it,
the world shall be covered
in darkness.
Fire!
The Dark Lord is currently
in a deep sleep.
To wake him,
it would require the Wand.
I'm hiring you with this.
Hey girl, why don't you hire me?
You're the first orc I've met
who shows proper manners.
And you're a human,
but you don't seem to show any.
My girl!
Master Koketsu, why?
Izou, you made a promise to Sonya.
You'll keep it, won't you?
You can see it too,
the light and darkness.
You're losing your mind
over a mere runaway elf girl.
Why?
Because I made a promise.
Izou!